[Musique]
nous sommes à l'école primaire saint
norbert une des plus importantes de
laval comme à tous les jours le
directeur est nerveux jours est-ce qu il
manque quelqu'un ce matin dans les
classes ok parfait je le vois il craint
qu encore une fois des élèves se
retrouvent sans enseignants ce qui
arrive fréquemment dans son école type
récupère quand on arrive un matin il
manque deux trois quatre personnes
je suis allé dans la tasse mais
effectivement il y avait une suppléante
qui était sur place donc tout est
correct pour aujourd'hui pour
aujourd'hui meilleur meilleur c'était
plus difficile loin hier une situation
il manquait deux enseignantes dans leur
classe
le problème est le même partout au
québec il manque deux suppléants à cause
de la pénurie d'enseignants
à la commission scolaire de laval on
était capable de combler l'absence d'
environ un enseignant sur quatre sites
pour un suppléant pour une place pour
une journée balle à ce moment là le
dépannage fait que un enseignant par
exemple de 6e année puissent faire la
première période en 2e année pour la
deuxième période
d'autres enseignants de haut niveau donc
oui ça pourrait arriver que ce soit 4 5
enseignants
le manque de suppléant est elle à laval
qu'en février pendant une semaine
142 demande de suppléance n'ont pas été
comblées c'est 40 % des requêtes et de
plus un an
le problème prend de l'ampleur sept
suppléants y est confronté régulièrement
c'est quand même vraiment votre combat
là tout le monde cherche gates était à
30 élèves ou quelques d'élèves qui
auront pas de professeur pour margerie
une enseignante de la rive sud de
montréal
cette pénurie affecte tout le monde dans
les écoles j'ai une collègue de travail
ou treize personnes dans sa classe en
rotation l'eau on parle pas à la période
on parle à la journée une personne rend
une journée le lendemain c'est quelqu'un
d'autre
le lendemain c'est quelqu'un deux jours
et ainsi de suite pendant des semaines
ici au centre d'appel de la commission
scolaire de laval où on traite les
demandes de suppléance chaque jour
céline et décourager encore aujourd'hui
il lui manquait aux remplaçants c'est un
peu comme si à avancer seul à bord au
début car ça arrivait à des soirées
comme ça en partant du simple rendu
haute parce que c'est trop difficile on
n'était pas habitué à vivre ce donc
manière pour le 18
résultat c'est le personnel des écoles
qui est qu à ses traditions et je vous
dirais qu'il ya des gens qui se privent
de prendre des congés
parce qu'on part que ce soit leurs
collègues qui payent pour dans la région
de montréal on s'arrache les suppléants
à laval on l'a même abaisser les
critères d'embauché pour en attirer
avant pour être suppliant la commission
scolaire de laval fallait avoir un
minimum de 30 crime dit
un enseignement dans son bac alors
maintenant on a diminué à 15 crédits
pour la commission scolaire c'est une
façon de recruter des suppléants comme
eve marie une étudiante qui vient de
décrocher un contrat à l'école saint
norbert
en 2ème année d'avant premier contre
tellement et mangue des personnels le
directeur souhaite qu'on revalorise la
profession qu'un plus grand nombre de
jeunes prennent le chemin de
l'université pour étudier en éducation
et 6 janvier provient en radio canada
laval
[Musique]